well I mean the orange truth is this was
a very big surprise to me the casting
I am a musician
and I have music videos and I've always
loved acting so I've acted in my music
videos and I co-direct my music videos
and I create the art dialogue and I've
even done a small fight scene in my
music video called bad friend which I
really really enjoyed and I was thinking
that would be so cool if I can do action
it'd be amazing and then I got a call
from Chad the director and he wanted to
speak to me and he pretty much said here
is how it is it's really hard training
you don't have to keep up with Keanu you
know I do really long takes and are you
up for it are you free in the next
couple months and so I left a couple
days later and I was in Berlin training
wow that's hot